[Music]
the earth has an elegant cycle of life
it's the story of carbon and over
billions of years it has evolved to look
something like this it starts with a
plant plants and microorganisms absorb
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere then
they use energy from the Sun to convert
that carbon into oxygen and sugar which
they used to grow and as they grow they
emit some carbon back into the
atmosphere but all plants eventually die
and some are consumed by bacteria others
by larger beasts these animals eat
plants for energy and they breathe out
carbon but eventually those animals die
too
and they end up in the ground meanwhile
a similar thing happens in the ocean
coral and plankton need carbon from the
water to survive
luckily the ocean has carbon because it
absorbs some from the atmosphere and
when rain falls to the earth it grabs
some carbon from the atmosphere and from
rocks and flows into the ocean where the
coral and plankton used carbon to grow
or other animals use it to grow but just
like animals the coral and plankton die
too in short all living things are made
of carbon and they eventually end up in
the ground some of that carbon will
eventually get back to the atmosphere
but some of it normally stays in the
ground
usually dead things decay and turn into
rocks eventually they are crushed and
the extreme heat and pressure causes
them to melt and emit the carbon which
is trapped underground
over time that trapped carbon eventually
escapes into the atmosphere when
volcanoes erupt and the cycle starts
again but occasionally dead plants and
animals don't turn into rock
they don't decay fast enough so they
turn into oil coal or natural gas
this carbon gets stuck in the ground
this is the elegant system that keeps
carbon cycling through earth at a steady
pace carbon in the atmosphere keeps some
heat from leaving earth it keeps earth
at a stable temperature but very
recently one of these animals started to
dig up the carbon in the ground they
took the carbon that was stuck in the
ground and put it back into the
atmosphere and they did this so much in
such a short time span that the cycle
was disrupted too much carbon was being
put into the atmosphere heap that would
normally be able to escape bounced back
and stayed on earth and earth started to
get warmer and warmer really recently
just a few months ago more than 100
bipedal scientists said they might only
have 12 years to stop a disastrous
amount of warming so these animals not
only need to stop putting carbon in the
atmosphere but also get carbon out of
the atmosphere
they found one way to remove carbon is
to grow more plants they could stop
cutting down trees or raise livestock in
ways that help restore grass another way
is to let plants suck up carbon from the
atmosphere but then burn them for energy
and then trapping the carbon they emit
underground they could also build
machines
to suck air from the atmosphere and
filter out the carbon but they haven't
figured out how to do this fast enough
there are many ways these animals can
treat the cycle to suck carbon out of
the atmosphere a combination of them is
probably the best way forward but first
these animals need to figure out how to
stop putting it there in the first place
if you haven't heard already we've
launched a paid membership program on
YouTube called a box video lab for a
small payment you have access to some
amazing perks like access to live
streams with our creators and a little
badge that appears next to your name and
it'll upgrade over time this is the best
way to support our channel it'll help us
do more ambitious journalism so we could
bring better content to you guys if you
want to learn more just head to vacuum
slash join